at 10 a.m on saturday china was brought
to a halt
[Music]
the national flag was flown at half-mast
across the country
cars and trains sounded their horns and
air-raid sirens were set off
as the nation paid its respects to those
who've lost their lives to the
coronavirus
in the city where the outbreak
originated people took to the streets
bowing their heads in a moment of
silence to mourn the dead
they also thanked medical workers on the
front line in wuhan
i think it is really moving what our
chinese medical staff has done
as well as those fighters who have
sacrificed themselves i feel very
emotional
oh i want to cry now as i'm speaking i'm
really moved
more than 3 000 medical workers across
china have been infected
at least five doctors at wuhan central
hospital have died
including li wen lung he was one of the
first to share
information about the coronavirus but
was reprimanded by the city's police
what happened to these people was very
unfortunate we should mourn for them
lee wen lang was a hero he found out
about it early
now it's too late but our country is
stronger than others
the day of mourning coincided with the
start of the annual tombsweeping
festival quingming
millions of families traditionally visit
cemeteries to pay respects to their
ancestors
this year they were told to stay home
there is an epidemic but this is china's
tradition we can't cast it aside
but as china starts to ease restrictions
other countries in asia
are introducing tough new measures to
force people to stay at home
thailand has imposed a countrywide
curfew and all international flights are
banned for three days
in south korea the government says it
will bolster its social distancing
efforts
after a recent rise in imported cases of
the virus
we cannot loosen restrictions for the
moment if we were to do so all of the
efforts we have made could be in vain
south korea recorded another 94 new
cases on saturday
bringing the national tally to more than
10 100
but despite an overall downward trend in
cases
all religious sports entertainment
facilities and schools
are to stay closed sarah clark al
jazeera